how can I pay child support how if my
ex-wife is destroying my name and I
can't work the explosive r.kelly
interview with Gayle King continues now
CBS this morning is sharing an inside
look at the RMV legends financial
struggles this is just one day after
Kelly was taken into custody due to over
one hundred and sixty one thousand
dollars in unpaid child support payments
his rep told eetzi the singer offered to
pay fifty to sixty thousand dollars in
court on Wednesday and set up a payment
plan but the judge denied that offer the
52 year old expressed shock when it was
rejected his rep adds quote you could
see the Ergo out of him he never
expected that here's what he told King
about his money troubles before his
arrest
what is your financial situation if you
don't mind saying here's the deal so
many people have been stealing my money
people was connected to my account I
went into I went by myself for the first
time to Bank of America didn't know what
I was doing didn't know what the hell
was going on when did you do that first
time by yourself three weeks ago two a
month three weeks ago was the first time
you went to Bank America by yourself by
myself because I was so tired of not
knowing where my money was what my
publisher is isn't that what you then
huh isn't that on you a lot of it's all
that you didn't know what your money is
a lot of it's all me and people say he
doesn't have money because he had to pay
so much in settlements what do you say
about that laughs Kelly says he had
about three hundred and fifty thousand
dollars and he wanted to start a new
account but it would take a week to
clear now he claims that his ex-wife
Andrea Kelly lied in the lifetime
documentary abused her Robert being
married
I flew in on a helicopter
I flew in on a helicopter
yeah yeah can somebody go to sushi not
once have I ever had a domestic violence
call at the house and all this than the
other it never happened you being abused
miss Andrea not telling the truth when
she said she was abused by you why are
you making that up Robert I'm not
disrespecting her by saying she's not
telling the truth I'm just being honest
somebody sent me some of my phone and
said that a-hole Tyler this is not a lie
and Kelly's next court date is set for
March 13th for child support and again
on March 22nd for his sex abuse
allegations Detroit police confirm they
are also investigating Kelly for
allegedly having sex with a teenage girl
almost two decades ago yeah that's a
separate case we're dealing with now
Gayle King also sat down with our
Kelly's live-in girlfriends 23 year old
Joycelyn savage and 21 year old Ezreal
Clary
I think the interviews with the girls
are very fascinating and very revealing
what is your relationship both of you
with with our Kelly we're with him
that's what it is
and we're in a relationship with him
right a very strong relationship as well
yes most definitely
following Kings interview she opened up
to et about the energy in the room when
you talk to them they get very angry
they're very angry at their parents they
say that this is all about money that
their parents were trying to get money
from our Kelly that they've gotten money
from our Kelly in the past that they
their parents introduced them to our
Kelly so it really is a lot of he said
she said they said it's just it's a big
mess all the way around in this
is it a three-way sexual relationship
actually well I'm here to talk about my
personal life and I would never share
with no one what I do in or outside of
the bedroom and as a woman I'm sure you
would not either you know I wouldn't but
I okay then tell me you question both
savage and Clary's parents have spoken
out publicly fearing their daughters
have been brainwashed into being part of
an alleged sex cult something both girls
adamantly deny tell me I'm sure while
you're crying tell me they got very
emotional and they wish that their
parents would stop in their words lying
on them they wish their parents would
leave them alone they said they're very
happy they're very safe and they both
love our Kelly and they are both his
girlfriends of course this story is
still developing so subscribe to all
things et and we'll make sure to keep
you up to date with all the latest
details as they unfold until next time
I'm Hallie Stevens and I'm Courtney teza
know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]